we know each other I don't have a lot of
friends outside of show business but you
and I are have been friendly over the
years and I've gotten to know you a bit
and so I'm always curious how your love
life is going I think I'm allowed to ask
because I'm a friend I'm not asking in
that like tabloid way but you know is
there a guy right now I'm asking you on
a talk show these cameras they're just
made of cardboard they don't feel so you
know I've had you know I've had some
good ones and I've had some turns you
know I have you refer to a bad boyfriend
is a turn I turn yeah watching right now
and they know they're you have a good
one please this went down a road I never
thought actually my niece's wedding
mm-hmm he's a guitarist and we I saw him
and you know one time on the date you
bested my mojo because you came up and
you're like hey Chris and I'm like I'm
on date that way Conan and then this
time it happened with my dad your dad
came busted my mouth oh there he was
like hey hey what are you doing talking
and I was like let me have a moment to
see if I'm gonna go out with this guy
but he's so sweet he's kind he's a good
spirit and I'm sure it'll end tomorrow
but I really like to say that you know
this is this is something that I've been
wanting to complain you about hi my wife
and I invited you over to our house for
dinner and you brought this boyfriend
and you you said can I bring my
boyfriend alone we're like yeah we
thought if you're bringing this guy
along I think if you're bring him along
this is really gonna go the distance
yeah I mean it's a great honor to be
invited to my home
and I love that I'm making this about me
and then I think the next time I saw you
which was not long afterward you're like
oh yeah no I dropped that guy and I was
like I had him to my another chance I
mean that laughter the whole three
months this three is three months that's
a good amount of high isn't that like
seven years they cat that's how you
measure your your relationships okay
it's it's a quarter yeah yeah it's a
financial quarter but this is been a
year or so will smack like you better
hear that's great
yeah for me like I mean I'm not in a bad
way like a long time right right well
well you give me going so well it's like
death yeah in that it's a release from
pain anywho well I'm glad if you think
he's you know okay come over but I don't
I'm just worried that you're gonna come
over I'm gonna like the guy and then I'm
gonna see you two days later he's like
well he was just an extra long turd no
Mike what no first of all you're going
to love him because he loves you and he
will laugh at all your jokes also a very
empty man
[Music]